thanks yeah I'm Alex debris I worked at
auto as a data engineer in Omaha
Nebraska I'm Kelly burning I work at
huddle on the wave data analyst their
prior to that was in the Air Force for
six years and I worked in intelligence
after that I worked a huge strategic
command business all sorts cameras off
it the first phase of Nebraska and then
for the last year and a half I've been
at home cool so we're going to talk
about promoting a data-driven culture in
a world of micro services and so it's
gonna be a lot of using data for
internal out analytics at your company
you know figure out which products are
being used how your features are being
used or not used user engagement things
like that for internal use so just a
quick overview will give you an
introduction to huddle and what huddle
does then we'll talk about Huddle's
production data journey and data
problems that came up and then our
solution to it with two teams data
engineering gating analytics and the key
takeaways and a summary so yeah we work
for huddle we're a sports video and
analytics company based in Nebraska we
started with high school football teams
and basically have all that market about
ninety six percent of the high school
football teams in America use us so now
we've expanded out to other high school
sports in America and then also
grassroots also more elite level like
College of Professional and
internationalist we've got EPL teams
we've got NBA teams things like that so
just a rundown on how the product works
imagine you're a high school basketball
coach you have a game you'd set up a
camera or iPad to record your game
you've also got a manager or a parent
you know that's tagging the game saying
you know assists made shots pitch shots
things like that and then after the game
you can break down the data share with
your coach to share with your ear
players skipped all the three pointers
many things like that and then yeah just
to give you a number of the scale an
idea of the scale were working at how
about four and a half billion video
views in the last year about five
million users and 100
2000 teams so yeah we'll talk about our
data journey so this is our we got
started in 2006 and basically the web
app was backed by just a single
Microsoft sequel server so everything's
pretty easy there all the production
data is in there it's easy to run
analytics on that then in 2010 we're
starting to scale a little bit we have a
lot of clips in particular so we need to
split out some of our data models in the
two MA go so now our data split between
mago and sequel server but still pretty
easy right like most of its in these two
places and the important stuffs really
in sequel server so you can it's still
pretty easy to do analytics but then
2014 now we're trying to scale our
product team and we move to a micro
service architecture so now we've got
two different services that are talking
to each other that each have their own
[ __ ] database and we've still got the
sequel server there also in 2014 we do
an acquisition so we bring in a Mike
Rizzo and they brought in a my sequel
server so now I've got a couple
different databases then 2015 you know
now we've got a bunch of different
microservices there's [ __ ] database as
well all over the place stood up the
seagull servers and then we've also got
just a ton of application logs some
things you want to keep in a production
database like you know could views or
highlight views or just all kinds of
things like that so now we have data
problems right and so like every year we
have you know four or five key metrics
we want to track we caught our mountain
goals and one of our mountain goals for
2015 was to keep track of all football
teams that had three reward users
watching video in three different months
we call that engage team and it was a
key goal for us you know our bonuses
were tied to it and so we wanted to
track it really well week / week see how
we're doing but to pull that data you
need to go to a you know the users [ __ ]
and since you need to go sequel server
and get info about teams in schools and
then you need to search through a bunch
of logs to see who's watching video and
this is just a real pain and to do that
someone needs all these different skills
right they need to know how to SSH into
your production machine
which is scary and then they no sequel
they mail [ __ ] query that language and
then Excel or Python or whatever they're
going to do to sort of tie all that
together so in the middle of 2015 we
said this isn't working we need to do
something so we spent up to New squads
data engineering and data analytics and
that's basically we'll talk about is
what the responsibilities of each of
those squads are how it's worked for us
so yeah de engineering I'm on the
engineering team our product team in
like 2010 they had a sort of a rallying
call for coaches who are the users are
saying basically give me my damn video
bar rallying call is just giving my damn
data so everyone within huddle you know
wants to access the data without having
to go to all these different databases
so we have three big questions right
we've got data in all these different
databases we've got log files all that
stuff where do we put that data how does
it get there and then how do people
access it once it is there so where do
we put that data you know there's our
site we showed before with all the
different databases pretty easy here we
just jam it all in amazon redshift which
has been huge for us so a little bit
about amazon redshift it's just a sequel
based database that's it's built for
like large analytical queries it's fully
managed on rich on am AWS which is great
because all the rest of our
infrastructures on AWS and it's pretty
pretty reasonably priced for like the
amount of storage and compute get robbed
story he works at simple financier
really good talk at higher Chicago I
thought about how to how to sort of
tailor your schema and redshift and just
some tips they had yours what are
experience as well so I'd recommend
going to look at that alternatives you
know if you're on google cloud you can
use Google bigquery if you're more of a
do-it-yourselfer you can use hive Impala
or some of the newer ones like presto or
druid if you're an enterprise user I
think there's vertica tear data from the
house familiar with you check those out
so yeah so that our bigger question is
like how does our day to get there right
like in this previous picture I showed
you know we're going to put it on Amazon
friendship that blue arrow is really
like the key work of what data
engineering does in particular we just
do a lot of ETL word extract transform
and load so it's a very simple example
you know imagine you have a mic sequel
database and you want to make me maybe
all your users are in there and you want
put them into ames on red chip so you
can join them with you know other tables
from other databases you're just going
to extract transform and load right and
like that's a pretty simple path right
there you can probably take three hours
and write up the script that pulls it
out saves its disk you know does little
transformation on it and then inserts
into redshift pretty easy then the
script takes 15 minutes to run but in
reality you know you're going to have a
lot of ETL steps because you need one
for every table in your database you
have a lot of different transformations
and lows and all that stuff and also
like each of those things is going to
fail right so you just want to build
something reliable there and I would say
and I definitely use a workflow manager
there a couple good ones out there Luigi
which is open source by Spotify that's
what we use and we love it air flow is a
little newer one by Airbnb at Lincoln
has a screen as well great thing about
Luigi and airflow is Aaron Python I
think there have been a few talks today
about both both of these and I'm you
know in that past PI data so you can go
and check the videos online but the
three big things they'll give you is
like dependency management right so you
need to like before you love transform
and load your data you need to make sure
it's extracted it will make sure you do
that in order for you parallelism so if
you have one instance of your ETL job
running you can Robin you can spin up
another one as well and it will be
working on different tables and then I
dense if it fails in the middle of the
job you don't have to worry about sort
of all these weird files all over the
place or incomplete loads you can just
rerun the whole job if you don't know
what has been done what happened to
doing all that i also just think really
hard about your tooling and make sort of
repeatable processes I showed this you
know just like this big blue pipe that
goes in amazon redshift but in reality
what you'll have is like
different types and you don't want to
have to be like reinventing the wheel
for each one of those right so you need
to work we're not like scheduling and
logging and monitoring and did it work
all that stuff and like you start off
with cron and you just have like this
cron script on some server somewhere and
that just turns into a mess quickly we
started using Jenkins which is like a
really good replacement for cron I would
for just vanilla cron you know it's got
a great UI but not great guy it has a UI
that you guys do which is nice and then
also just like logging you can you can
you know go to the web interface and see
all the logs right there you can have it
send slack notifications if a jump
finish successfully or did not finish
successful you things like that and then
you have a couple different kinds of
triggers so if you want to just you know
right on schedule with cron you can use
that we can also do dependency base so
as soon as this job finishes you know
now run this job and this job in this
job or just like get check-in triggers
as well so we have jenkins and then i
would say we have two big sort of
buckets of jobs that we have we have
like we have single machine jobs and
these are ones that can run you know
maybe in 30 minutes to an hour on us on
that Jenkins box directly and they're
not going to tax it and take it down and
so we just run those straight to Luigi
on the Jenkins box those would be things
like you know go to zendesk and get all
our tickets from the last day go to
salesforce maybe a few different Google
sheets that like the sales teams pass
around and it will extract those and put
it into red shift and it's pretty easy
our second big pattern is like multi
machine jobs and that's going to be
pulling everything out of a database
doing [ __ ] Processing's you know
turning like a [ __ ] document into
something that fits a relational model
more so doing bigger jobs like that and
for that we just spin up amazon EMR
instances which you know as you go to
manage like a cluster of machines really
well and then we've just got a pattern
down where you know you make a directory
with all your scripts in it has a run
script in it and you load it
to a particular spot on s3 and it's easy
to schedule that job amaro pull down
that directory unzip and run the run
script and it's pretty easy and reliable
that way so then on EMR what will happen
there is also Luigi script either
calling you know spark or Scoob or
something else like that and then final
question for data engineering is how do
people access the data right we put it
all in red shift like what's sort of the
access pattern that's here i put in red
shift we have pugliese on the far right
there that's our logo and it's like how
do they how they interact with with
redshift a basic overview of our needs
we want everyone in our company to have
access to read ship so we've got four
hundred thirty employees we want every
single one of them to be able to get to
it they need to and we have a fair bit
of data we've got 24 terabytes in red
shift with 100 billion plus rose so
there's a lot in there and like a bad
query can slow it down so we need to be
careful about that commercial options we
looked at hooker and periscope are to
the real hot ones right now for us given
those needs before that was kind of
infeasible one of them charges per row
and then one of them charges per user so
I think both of these would have been
pretty expensive for us and then tableau
also is very popular but again charges
per row so women a per user so would've
been expensive for us to get full earned
30 people on it so we use read ash which
is a completely open source tool back
end written in Python it's got a very
nice query editor and visualizations the
maintainer Eric he's great on it and
he'll he'll accept contributions will
give you feedback all that I think he
just got a Mozilla open-source grant
which is awesome he's also gotten a
hosted version that you can go and pay
for it's very reasonably priced compared
to liquor in Paris probe so that's great
or you can host your own that's what we
do we put on ec2 instance and her own so
yeah now we have basically you have that
that sort of top mess there now it's all
being fed into amazon redshift you can
query it through read ash cuddlies are a
lot happier instead of having all these
different skills you needed to get
access to our data now it's just down to
right and then that's sort of where our
data analytics team comes in helping our
internal uglies get through the sequel
aspect so I'll turn over to Kelly
alright afternoon so the mission of the
data analytics team at huddle is to help
our employees leverage data to make
better decisions so you know a good
chunk of our work is us digging into the
data analyzing it building models making
recommendations and measuring the
outcomes but another big part of our job
is helping all of our employees pull
data and analyze it themselves we have a
kind of unique structure at huddle our
organization is very flat if you're
familiar with like the Spotify product
organization it's very similar to that
so we all work in very small very
autonomous teams called squads and so
for example a squad on the product team
they are pushing code very fast which is
one of the reasons we have this type of
organization and so they need to be able
to make decisions on a daily basis and
so if we want to be data-driven you know
everybody everybody has to buy in to
data okay so everybody needs access to
data and everybody needs to know how to
pull it and analyze it so this kind of
leads us to our data philosophy which is
we give access to our entire entire data
warehouse to every single one of our
employees so we have all of our data
under one roof as Alex explained and now
everyone is access so problem solved
right now we can be data-driven well not
quite so turns out finding data still
isn't so easy at huddle at this point
you still need sequel to be able to pull
the data which it can be a high bar for
some people especially when you're
talking about you know someone maybe in
marketing or business background that
you know has really no coding experience
on top of that we just have a ton of
data for a company of our size so you
know we have over 10 billion rows spread
across 540 tables coming from you know
20 to 40 different sources so a column
in one table that is the equivalent to a
column in another table but it's not
name the same so it gets really complex
and that's really difficult for somebody
who's not sitting there working in data
every single day on top of that we have
a pretty small data team we have two
data engineers and three data analysts
so trying to take requests for data for
you know 430 plus people would be pretty
daunting and probably next to impossible
so what can we do well we need to remove
these roadblocks so everybody can have
true access to data and so we've done a
number of things so far that we found to
be very successful and so the first one
of these things is education so we have
something at huddle called huddle
University it's just an internal
training program where employees offer
certifications and various topics and
teach other employees on those topics so
I'm sure a lot of you that work for
larger corporations probably have
something similar and so I basically
developed two courses a beginning sequel
course and an intermediate sequel course
and taught it in the context of our own
data so not only are they learning
sequel but this allows them to learn you
know where data is stored and how to
answer very common questions at huddle
and just kind of the basic data model
that we have as well as how to use our
interface to to red shift which is read
ash and some basic data visualization
techniques and so once I started
offering these they were very popular we
had probably 100 to 150 people go
through the courses and the number of
people querying on a daily basis just
went through the roof so it was very
successful if you don't have kind of an
internal training program like this at
your company you know something like a
lunch and learn a lecture also good
things I've also there's a lot of great
online resources out there as well and
I've been reading recently a lot of
companies actually requiring kind of
some basic sequel knowledge for you
kind of the business side of operations
so just kind of something to think about
another problem we had is you know with
it being so much data you know how do
you find which table has the data you
need so for example if one of our
employees wanted to find information
about the schools that certain teams
belong to they could go to the query
editor and look up the school's table
and so okay we see the table we see a
bunch of columns listed there in a basic
overall data type but that's about it
but since read ash is open source that
allows us to kind of edit it and make it
fit our needs and so we went ahead and
developed and built out what we call a
data dictionary and so people can click
on the table and now you get a table
description as well as descriptions of
each of the columns which is being very
helpful you can also search by that and
that will pop up we also added kind of a
relationship chart so this shows you
every column that is in that schools
table that has a relationship with any
other table in our data warehouse as
well as the relationship type and the
column that it needs to be joined on so
no no fancy diagram yet but it's still
kind of a work in progress but this
really helped a lot so now when people
have questions we can kind of steer them
here so another very valuable resource
so the next thing that we did was
something that we call derive tables and
so this is basically a way to take messy
data which I'm sure you're all very
familiar with and kind of just make it
look not so messy on the other end so
I'll give you an example so let's go
back to that question that Alex
mentioned about one of a big goals so
find how many football teams had three
or more users watch video in three
different months this year okay so we
only need to know sequel right we don't
need to know all the skills that you
mentioned before but we still have to
look across four tables do three joins
one Union an aggregation and you have to
know at least four different
combinations of key value pairs that
signify various type
of watching video well if you heard all
that but not very easy to remember
especially if you're not working in this
every day so that was that was really
tough for people is confusing there was
also some performance issues when you're
looking back over a year two years of
this so we created a kind of a
simplified version where we pull out the
unique user ID and team ID for every
single day of a person that did various
activities so you see here we just have
the user ID team ID the date that they
did it and then boolean actions for
watching video tagging video uploading
video this is kind of just like a simple
version we have quite a few actions
listed in this table but it's really
simplified things for people some of you
might be wondering why we didn't just do
like a view there's kind of some
performance issues there and so storage
for us is pretty cheap it's that you
know computing cost is you know what
gets you so that's why we made a
separate table as opposed to of you okay
so something else you did is report
automation with things like tableau
that's pretty easy but again that's
really expensive and so we're looking
for a better option and this is one of
the reasons read ash again an open
source tool was so attractive to us
because it allowed us to easily automate
and schedule queries and reports you
know without the cost so for example
every query can go in and be edited by
any user to schedule at various time
intervals so you know if they need to
know the numbers multiple times a day
just once a week once a month it's done
so now you don't have to go in every
single day and hit run on these queries
something you can also do is create
dashboards and so you can have all these
queries updating on you know the time
interval that you specified but you can
kind of aggregate them all into one
dashboard and so you know you have one
common theme for a dashboard you can see
all your data visualizations it's right
there
so it really simplifies things and you
know brings the metrics straight to
these users so we can build out
dashboards for these teams you know they
don't need to know the sequel you know
and they we can just deliver the metrics
to them and then they can even download
the raw data behind behind the outcomes
themselves so it's super helpful
something else that we've done we use
slack at huddle for all our inner office
communications and so often teams are
you know spread across multiple offices
so that's often there their main form of
communication and so kind of like well
you know we're relying on people to go
to these dashboards you know every day
and check their metrics but what if we
just bring the metrics right to them so
imagine like a product team and you have
a product manager who's really trying to
rally his team one around one metric for
a quarter let's say you know and so this
is something they want to improve every
single day on and they want to be
looking at and so we wrote a script in
Python that works with the scheduler and
read ash and delivers the metric or the
visualization right into slack and drops
in the channel and so here's kind of an
example of what that might look like and
so you know every morning you maybe have
a warning stand up or something banned
there's your metric right there now you
can talk about it so just to kind of
show you some of the success that we've
had just in last month we had 194 unique
users execute a query out of 430
employees we had about 14,000 ad-hoc
queries executed and we have a little
over nine hundred forty unique scheduled
queries that run every single week and
some of those run multiple times in a
week as well so you know our our team at
huddle has really bought into using data
and be more data-driven obviously we
still have a lot of work to go this this
is not the end of our journey but we've
been very you know proud of our success
so far there are some cons to this
obviously giving access giving data
access to everybody can cause some
issues people pull bad day
think is good data make bad decisions
and also sometimes people write poor
performing queries that slow down the
whole system so and we've we've created
some checks kind of for those things so
kind of the key takeaways here being
data-driven is really a team sport you
can't just have one leader at the top
trying to be data-driven everybody needs
to buy into it everybody needs access
also important is getting the data
architecture in place so I think this is
a really good example of you know using
open source tools to get your data
architecture in place but you might have
hiccups along the way we used hive at
one point didn't work out so well and so
getting it right is really important
otherwise the longer you go on you just
create more more technical dead making
data and metrics accessible and this
doesn't have to mean you give every
single employee access to the raw data
but at least the metrics that they need
is really really important and then
being flexible you know this structure
works really well for us but this
architecture might not work well for
your company but there's a lot of ways
that you kind of piece together open
source tools you know without having to
pay a lot for commercial tools to make
it work and so being flexible and
understanding the needs of your company
is really really important ok so just
kind of summary of what we talked about
today as well as again a review of some
of the tools and which ones are in
python and with that i'll open it up for
any questions you guys might have
yes
yeah that's a great question and the
question was are you know what's our
adoption rate for more advanced sequel I
think on our products I'd essentially
for developers who are familiar with
code a lot of times they you know
they're very willing to kind of try that
out themselves but as did analytics we
do take requests so a lot of times
people will just go ahead and kind of
request it for us or sometimes they'll
give it a try it doesn't work out send
us what they have so far and will kind
of take it from there I'd say in the
business side probably less adoption but
once we've seen some of these people go
through and if they kind of graduate the
certification program we've seen really
good results so I would say it's kind of
a mix any other questions yes
yes we have a keep a few different
things but usually they'll be part of
just like a cron job or part of the
actual Luigi job that even load some of
the data into redshift might refresh
some of those tables as well so most of
our stuff happens like our production
databases are just on overnight jobs
blogs we load in every six hours and
then we in batches of during season now
I would say like Thai 70 or 80 million
logs will load in every six hours yeah
that one will be Knightly yep
no yeah and that's like definitely a
problem to in like the same thing Kelly
mentioned to it like sort of like bad
queries can sort of in fact like read
ash has like a copy query button so
someone write a bad query and then
someone else copy it and then just like
it's really hard to stomp it out but
like we work on that too and yeah
there's no sort of way to get rid of
that but most of our queries i would say
run under you know 30 seconds or so so
it's not a huge with you yes so the
question is how is it a dictionary
created and so for like the the table
metadata stuff like you know the table
name and the type that's just taken
directly from the ratio stima and then
so then each table will have a web page
you can go to and just like an editable
editable description block so that's
sort of like user filled in data all the
descriptions stuff and then same with
relations between tables someone needs
to like go and fill that in but like our
data analyst you at your great gamma
doing that and then just like other
people that have knowledge and
experience about particular tables
they'll go in and sort of an idea for
other people
is there any why Howie energies you know
yeah so I can talk a little bit about
that um so we did use the API to slack
and I think you just need like the team
ID and then you actually type in like
the channel we used a Python package I
think it's called slacker and so we use
that and then and then we just connected
to the read ash API and so we kind of
pull it all into the Python script and
then push it back out into slack so it
doesn't interface with red ship directly
like read ash will like this is these
are usually scheduled queries that have
charts already generated so it'll say
like don't get the latest run of that
scheduled query and then just paste it
in the slack
I go so I guess the question was we have
a jira ticket tracking system and does
the interface no we don't pull that in
we have had a request for it and we
haven't gotten to it
yeah so the question is how hard is read
ash to get up and going and it's really
easy eric is maintainer and he's great
on it he has like Amazon am I images he
has google cloud platform images he's
got docker Heroku everything so you can
do it like in very simple instructions
to get that setup like we didn't have
any trouble getting at set up at all and
then he's also got the hosted version
which is like it which is very very
reasonable compared to sort of the other
paid options out there and add one thing
to that read ash was also very easy to
integrate with octa which is a you know
a security extension I'm for those II
not familiar and so that allowed
everyone in our company we can keep
accessed within our company and its
really easy for them to make a secure
connection without having password so
any other questions all right well thank
you for listening to our talk we
appreciate it